*here we see Markiplier planning to kill someone*
*Mark's ballad to express his opinion on a certain game that drains all sorts of happy*
*Mark losing it and making random sounds*
*Mark returns to his ballad to express his opinion on a certain game that drains all sorts of happy*
*Mark forgetting what English was*
*Mark being harassed by a plant*
*Mark being harassed by bats*
*seriously Mark needs help*
*Mark returns once more to his ballad to express his opinion on a certain game that drains all sorts of happy*
*Mark planning to kill someone*
*Mark returns once once more to his ballad to express his opinion on a certain game that drains all sorts of happy*
*Mark is everything okay*
*Mark returns once once once more to his ballad to express his opinion on a certain game that drains all sorts of happy*
*Mark those aren't words*
*Mark being harassed by a plant*
*Mark Singing his heart out while doing some tricky platforming*
*sounds of Mark's innocence being shattered by the one and only crash bandicoot*
*Mark reaching pretty high notes*
*Mark was singing the national anthem after all*
*mark singing his heart out once more throughout the final 9 seconds of this video*
*Markiplier Celebrating*